بالعوده الى القرار الامريكي بتزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل عنقوديه قدمت الولايات
المتحده في مختلف جولات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اسلحه نوعيه ساعدت كييف في
معاركها وفي تغيير مسار الحرب احيانا ابرز
هذه الاسلحه منظومه هاي مارس بعيده المدى
وعاليه الدقه بالاضافه الى صواريخ ستينجر
وجافلين ودبابات كما قدمت واشنطن انظمه
دفاع جوي متطوره منها الامريكيه واليوم
يجري الحديث عن القنابل العنقوديه التي
صممت لضرب الدبابات والعربات المدرعه
وتدميرها او تعطيلها على الاقل ويمكن ان
تغطي كل قنبله مساحه تصل الى 30 الف متر
مربع حسب الارتفاع الذي تطلق منه القنابل
الصغيره لكن هذه القدره تواجه اشكالا مهما
يتعلق بمعدلات فشل مرتفعه نسبه الخطا فيها
تبلغ سته في المئه وهي نسبه تضع تصديرها
واستخدامها امام عقبات قانونيه نسبه الخطا
هذه اوجدت خلافا كبيرا بشان وضع هذه
القنابل ضمن قائمه المساعدات عموما هناك
120 دوله وقعت على اتفاقيه خاصه تحضر
استخدام وتخزين وانتاج الذخائر العنقوديه
تقول منظمات دوليه ان كلا من روسيا
واوكرانيا استخدمت هذه الذخائر خلال الحرب
ذخائر لا ينفجر بعضها مما يشكل خطرا ولو
بعد سنوات ولذلك نرى شرطا امريكيا وضع
اليوم على كييف يلزمها بتحديدا دقيق
لاماكن استخدامها لمتابعتها في المستقبل
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من جنيف
الدكتور الكسندر رئيس تحرير المجله
العسكريه السويسريه دكتور اليكسوند ما
دلالات اقدام الولايات المتحده على هذه
الخطوه
هناك عدد من الاسباب اولا هناك
الذخائر التي يمكن ان تستخدم
لقصف قصف المدفعيه وهي تضر او اكثر فعاليه
باربع مرات من الذخائر التقليديه
المستخدمه هذا هو السبب الاول والسبب
الثاني هو ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعدد اخر من البلدان اللذيهم مخزون كبير
جدا من هذه الذخائر وهي بالتالي متاحه على
الفور لاوكرانيا ولكن ايضا
خطوه ماذا تقول لنا عن
يعني التقدم الذي تحرزه اوكرانيا في اطار
هذا الهجوم المضاد
لكل تاكيدا ان الهجوم المضاد وسلسله
العمليات الاوكرانيه المستمره من الجانب
الاوكراني ادت الى الرد فعلا قوي من
القوات المسلحه الروسيه وعلى وجه الخصوص
شهدت المنطقه هجمات مضاده من جانب الروس
وذلك من خلال استخدام
التقليديه وهنا تبرز او يبرز الحديث عن
هذه الذخائر العنقوديه التي يمكن ان
يستفيد منها الجيش الاوكراني لاستهدافي
المدرعات بالمقارنه مع الذخائر التقليديه
غير الفعاله كثيرا في هذه المجالات طيب
كيف هو التبرير الذي
لسان الرئيس الامريكي قبل قليل عندما قال
انه يجري اعطاء اوكرانيا هذه الذخائر
العنقوديه لان ذخيره اوكرانيا حاليا اخذ
في النفاذ
هذا صحيح وفي الوقت نفسه راينا
التحديات او راينا بالفعل القنوات
اللوجستيه القنوات اللوجستيه التي بنيت
لاشهر تحضيرا لهذه العمليه المضاده هناك
قنوات لوجستيه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عبر اوروبا وصولا الى اوكرانيا
وهذه القنوات اللوجستيه قويه للغايه وعدد
كبير من البلدان يشتري ذخائر جديده من اجل
الوفاء بالتزاماته تجاهه اوكرانيا وتزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخيره وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد
ان ذخيره سوف تنفذ في اوكرانيا لربما بعض
الانواع المحدده طبعا من الذخائر يصعب ان
تصل في القريب العاجل الى اوكرانيا هي
تتطلب وقتا اطول وهذا يعود بنا الى ضروره
تزويد اوكرانيا بالذخيره التي هي بح اجه
اليها في هذه العمليه المضاده
ستستخدم هذه الذخائر العنقوديه
ووفق المعلومات الغربيه روسيا ايضا تستخدم
هذه الذخائر العنقوديه ما المشهد الذي
يمكن ان نتوقعه ميدانيا
ميدانيا روسيا كما تفضلتي استخدمت وتستخدم
هذه الذخائر العنقوديه
وايضا استخدمت الاسلحه الحراريه في الوقت
نفسه
استخدمت اسلحه غير القانونيه لان هذه
الاسلحه تؤدي الى حرق
البناء والاشخاص داخل المباني كما تعرفون
ميدانيا معظم سكان تلك المناطق تم اجلائهم
يتحدثوا عن المناطق الحدوديه وبالتالي
التاثير المباشر على سكان المنطقه سوف
يكون محدودا على الارجح ولكن يجب ان ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار حقيقه ان بعض هذه الذخائر
قد تستخدم بطريقه اخرى
على كييف يلزمها بتحديد دقيق للاماكن التي
يتم فيها استخدام هذه القنابل حتى لا تشكل
قنابل موقوته في المستقبل خصوصا انها يمكن
ان تنفجر بعد سنوات هل هذا الشرط واقعي هل
يمكن فعليا حصر الضرر الكبير الذي تشكل
هذه الذخائر على الناس
هو واقعي وبالاضافه الى ما تفضلت به اليوم
هناك اداره عبر اجهزه الكمبيوتر اداره
اوتوماتيكيه من خلال من خلالها يمكن منع
استخدام الذخيره في مناطق محدده
وبالتالي هناك محدوديه لاستخدام هذه
الذخيره في المناطق الحضريه طبعا يجب
ايلاء هذه النقطه الاهتمام الضروري هناك
عدد كبير من الجيوش الذي يستخدم هذه
الذخائر العنقوديه ولهذه الذخائر قواعد
صارمه اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد اليكسون
العسكريه السويسريه ضيفنا من جنيف